if I think tomorrow I get all up in my
head so don't ever think it
well Billy Eilish definitely has fans in
their heads about this one because she
just unfollowed everyone on Instagram
and yes that includes Justin Bieber
why did your love for the Biebs starts
it started when I was like 12 I believe
did you posters in your room I did yeah
like big-ass ones while the 18 year old
has more than 64 million people
following her on the social media
platform fans noticed this week that the
Grammy winner isn't following anyone
anymore
I'd like to be judged so I want to I
want to see head look up check this out
Billy's page shows that she is following
one account but when you click on it
nothing comes up so we're guessing it's
just an instant which so yes the
self-proclaimed og belieber unfollowed
everyone even Justin's anyway the
motivation behind Billy's mass
unfollowing is unclear but some fans
claim that the Grammy winner allegedly
posted then deleted this pic to her
insta story reading if I am following
your abuser DM me and I will unfollow
them I support you et has reached out to
Billy's rep for clarification but one
thing is for certain
Billy is using her platform for good I
never in a million years would've
thought this would happen like I'm only
grateful for it for real the singer has
been speaking out on social media in
support of the black lives matter
movement and encouraging fans to take
the corona virus pandemic seriously I
wanted to just real quick say don't
panic but don't be an idiot you know
please take responsibility for your
endurance of this because yeah you could
get in you could be fine but you could
give it to your parents you could give
it to your grandparents your aunt's your
uncle's your friend's mom you know et
recently caught up with Billy's pal
Spice Girls is Melanie see and she
applauded the pop star for the way she
is using her fame what do you make of
how she losing her platform
I think she's incredible and she's using
it wisely and
you know she completely understands
she's so wise beyond her years she has a
very powerful platform you know to be
speaking from and she's using it in the
best way and it's brave as well you know
because everybody has an opinion and
everybody who's ready to criticize when
you're in those positions and you know I
feel extremely proud of her and you know
I feel for all younger artists now
because the Spice Girls didn't have to
deal with social media and no we very
different time and you know we felt
pressure we felt like we had a
responsibility to our younger fans but
now you know you are literally under the
spotlight and but she handles it
beautifully yeah my power too
[Music]